did you read any screenwriting books
while you were writing yeah
dialogue by Robert McKee story by Robert
McKee save the cat pretty much all of
them although all the famous ones
because I needed to learn you know more
better formatting stuff like that um
watched a lot of watched a lot of videos
learning how to appropriately write
character arcs and development story arc
and and those kinds of things so yes I
need a lot of a lot of different things
and did you already write the screenplay
before you started reading the books or
uh I had started because when I went to
school I had I had taken screenwriting
classes so I knew how to do it but the
the the books obviously very much helped
tighten everything up you know helped
solidify what I had already known and
give me confidence that okay I'm on the
right path as far as structure is
concerned how I'm on the right path as
far as how this character should evolve
and develop I truly believe in formula
and I think these books offer a really
solid formula that you can just color by
number you know I have an idea I have a
story this character needs to be this at
this point so let's get to that point
and so they've super helpful to tighten
everything up so you outlined obviously
because you said you you can go to
treatment treatment okay yeah I'm a free
I I'm a free writer
honestly I again I do my best work when
I just write I don't I don't want once
the stories out then I take time to
really flesh characters out which I
guess is outlining but I wrote the
treatment and a night I didn't I didn't
think about anything I didn't let my my
rule I didn't let rules get in the way
just just wrote it and then is when I
went back and said okay this character
gets to that point because of this so I
guess I outlined a little bit later but
not initially where did you write it
where were you when you're writing
the treatment I wrote in Orange County
this is when I was in school at your
apartment in my apartment in my house
and then when I came to LA I wrote the
script in my room yeah I set up my
computer to my big TV and just wrote to
the TV yeah oh nice so like huge suits
fond memory and just wrote it on the TV
as awesome it's good on the eyes yeah
yeah way better and then how long did it
take you to finish total would you say I
wrote the first draft in two and a half
months sat on it for six months like get
a fresh look and then when did the
rewrite in about three weeks and it's
about three and a half three and a half
months to write the whole thing paid for
writers - what's the script conference
get paid for coverage got coverage got
notes I learned probably the biggest
lesson I learned is that everyone has an
opinion and everyone will tell you their
version of the story so as long as you
trust your gut it's great to get notes
it's great to get notes but trust your
gut first because you're gonna get a
thousand different notes and people are
gonna tell you Oh what do you try this
and why don't you try that or try this
try that and I think honestly I used
maybe four or five of the notes that I
got from everyone a good coverage
because it was just so vast you know
that was really that was a really hard
experience for me was knowing what to
take that's a great no that's not a
great note that's okay that's that was
where the work came in that was where
the word came in was fixing according to
what they were offering and knowing that
you know I don't have to use that note
or that one's really good I will use it
and being okay with that you know but
that was really I think where the most
work came in was that I would love to
hear how you found the script consultant
without would give you other names
no no um so I went to the blacklist I
submitted there they responded with a
lot of different notes I went to I
applied for the Nichols fellowship they
gave me a ton of notes back I went to
writers workshops locally in LA and you
can just research a bunch
and I met other riders there who had who
had credits under their belt said hey
can can you do some coverage for me they
were always willing to you know pay them
a little bit of money and they were
always grateful to to just give me notes
and um that's where I found most my
coverage was from the writing workshops
is one networking with people in person
and doing it that way
and there's millions you can research
online millions do you mind me asking
how much you paid them
I'm just what's fair I mean ya know I I
because obviously you know the I mean
they weren't professional like a lot of
whom were professional did a lot of more
professional coverage I just know that
they had credits under their belt and so
I would just offer you know I'd say hey
100 bucks does that work for you and
they're like yeah sure and you know a
couple weeks or three weeks later I
would get some notes back and they were
always really fast turnaround so I was
surprised you know they always dedicated
some time to it which is great but yeah
I just offered what I could you know and
that's what another thing is is ask ask
first people are always willing to help
I got this film done because I just
asked first you know and then saying hey
what what can what can we do what kind
of thing can we work everyone in le
negotiates just get comfortable with
that language a negotiation language and
yeah just offer them what you can and
see what they can do and be be just be
should be grateful for whatever you can
get you know just be grateful and that's
that's pretty much what I found
how many coverage reports should you get
back kind of like six to eight maybe
solid ones and then and then the rest
were just from friends and people who I
knew growing up who I knew were in the
industry but really like six days solid
ones that were like okay you're a solid
professional who I can like trust you
know because you know you have your
friends Retd they're gonna either tell
you it's great or them say it's awful
reworking you're not going to be
specifics but I say coverage is great
because they can give you specifics you
know so you have six to eight people
that you met yeah they met at these
workshops Wow great great at doing it
yeah and
so that's where each time they gave you
notes back did you like how did that
work when you got their notes I'm sure
you probably looked at it whether you
considered it and did it yeah absolutely
the pattern I found is that everyone
like I said would typically give you
give your narrative notes and and I was
looking for more structural notes things
like does this character a get to point
Z by this time you know and does the
dialogue make sense and you know I
wasn't necessarily looking for someone
to to change the narrative as far as
like this guy meets this girl and
decides to do this with her but I got a
lot of that I got a lot of people like
well why don't you why does it have to
be this why don't you try this and those
were the kind of notes and I was like
valid but that's not where the story is
going this is the narrative this is the
path it's on does does point a get to
point B does point B get to point C yeah
and that's kind of the formula I found I
was kind of the routine I found yeah so
I would read the notes and then pick and
choose and that was the best part you're
getting to pick and choose what work and
what didn't you know and you don't have
to feel bad that they they understand
they understand if you don't pick
they're know if it's fine well they got
paid they got paid yeah that's whatever
yeah any advice to people on hiring a
script consultant and what if they've
never done it and there's someone where
they can hire them at a reasonable price
it's not like this you know yeah we're
definitely the blacklist
I mean it's they're super well known and
then they're professionals are so good
so good they they get back to you fairly
quickly and they always offer great
advice and they don't just say this is
wrong but they say this is what you
could also do to fix that they they it's
not just a minutes comp they give you
great compliments too they score you so
I would say look at the blacklist first
because it's a really good introduction
okay script coverage for sure and then
once you're working with the script
consultant anything any do's and don'ts
any red flags any anything that you
really want to encourage more of um be
open for collaboration as writers we're
always very precious of our work you
know but be open know that you are going
to fix things and be excited to cut be
excited to fix it's really hard
someone's using yourself and um to like
cut something but I remember when I made
my first cut suddenly like the doors
opened and I was like cutting everything
oh let's cut that and let's cut that
let's cut that and let's get that and
let's just make it streamline it you
know and then it got fun you know but it
took a little it took a little movement
with someone else saying hey but this is
why it could work you know and just be
open just be open for the consultant to
give you the right again you don't have
to take their advice but just be open
for it and if you're not open for it
just pretend you are because they're
doing you a service you know
you